hey it's Joey and welcome to better
ideas you probably heard the news cold
showers if the secret to unlocking your
inner potential and giving you
superpowers beyond your wildest dreams
now there are a ton of YouTube videos
and articles online you can find that
get into the nitty-gritty of exactly
what cold showers do to you
physiologically but what I'm more
interested in is what they do to you
mentally I actually gave a speech about
cold showers last semester for a public
speaking class I talked about the
physiological benefits as well as my own
experience with the 30-day cold shower
challenge now before we dive into what I
find is the most fascinating part which
is the mental benefit of cold showers
let's just do a quick review of the
physical benefits in case you're
uninitiated medical Daly says that cold
shower refines skin and hair and
rehydrates it makes sense because I mean
I don't know if you've ever taken a
really really hot long steamy shower
before you probably have is your human
often your hair gets really dried out
and your skin starts to actually you get
ashy elbows or something anyways cool
showers will stop that The Art of
Manliness says that according to a study
done by the drom BOCES Research Center
back in 1993 individuals who took daily
cold showers saw an increase in the
number of virus fighting white blood
cells compared to individuals who took
hot showers cool stuff still not the
coolest part that life hacker says that
a third benefit is that it stimulates
brown fat which is the good fat in your
body apparently that a lot of people
don't know about so the fact that you're
trying to get rid of is called yellow
fat and it's the bad undesirable fat
that usually collects around your
waistline in your tummy
Tommi stomach brown fat helps to eat
away at bad or yellow fat so basically
cold shower stimulates weight loss which
is often now there are a ton of other
benefits that people claim that cold
showers are responsible for like
increased fertility and men increased
testosterone and then a lot of men and
and mitigating symptoms of depression
now all these benefits sound like enough
reason to take a cold shower right now
and they probably are but when I find
the coolest part about cold showers is
what they do to you as a person which
kind of sounds like fluffy stuff but let
me break it down for you
first of all going back to the concept
of the flinch which I talked about in an
earlier video I'll put the link to the
description cold showers are extremely
uncomfortable even the mere thought of
having to take one makes you
uncomfortable despite the fact that you
have absolutely nothing to lose except
your comfort and all those benefits to
gain now think about all the things that
you're really proud of in life the
things that you put blood sweat and
tears into achieving how many hours of
discomfort did you put into achieving
those things but standing here in the
present day aren't you glad you went
through that anyway because the pain is
gone now and all that's remaining is the
result of your discomfort hard work and
perseverance so in a way cold showers
are the ultimate brain hack it forces
you right off the get-go to get into a
no pain no gain mentality it forces you
to scare way to flinch right when you
wake up so that when it comes time to do
schoolwork laundry fill out your taxes
it's absolutely nothing you'll just go
and do it there is no flinch anymore you
scared it away all of these little tasks
that you usually don't end up doing seem
like nothing in comparison to the cold
shower you took that morning you've
conditioned yourself to be comfortable
with the uncomfortable and you've
shifted your brains mentality from
instant gratification and momentary
pleasure to long-term gain and real
substantial benefit and that's why cold
showers are so powerful so I challenge
you go take a cold shower today it'll
suck but that's entirely the point if
you liked this video and want to see me
make more hit that subscribe button down
below
I love seeing these descriptions I also
like seeing your comments so if you
comment I will probably respond to it
and if not I will like it and I just
will appreciate it in general also
follow me on Twitter at better ideas TV
and right now we're in and around 100
subscribers so once we hit 250
subscribers I'll be doing the random
giveaway I don't know what that item
will be yet but all you need to do to
enter is hit that subscribe button down
below and you'll be automatically
registered thanks for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video